since it first released in 2014 I've had
a love-hate relationship with destiny at
its best it gave me thrilling co-op
strikes and multiplayer raids it also
felt better than most shooters I had
played with such fluid aiming and
satisfying gunplay that those games just
felt off in hindsight but for me and
many others there was also a dark side
to destiny aside with pointless missions
and wasted playtime frustrating loot
drops and constant disappointment the
taken King expansions somewhat rectified
these problems with a revamped
progression system but the late game
still lacked enough variety and reward
to make it feel like the hours we poured
into it were well spent with destiny -
developer Bungie yet again made strides
in some areas while digressing in others
early game loot was parsed out at a
better pace structured around a wider
variety of quests than its predecessor
had but still the RNG cloud hung over
everything faction rallies infuriated
players iron banner events never
guaranteed the items you wanted as was
always the case loot drops were more a
product of random numbers and what felt
like luck Bungie has patched its sequel
several times allowing players to buy
the specific items they want but much of
it feels like it's too little too late
the bottom line is the more I play
destiny the less assured I am that my
time will be worth it too much of it
feels up to chance
destiny demands that you spend a lot of
time with it but doesn't guaranteed that
that time will be a good investment for
me this paradox recently reached a
boiling point I fell off the destiny
train so to speak with so many other
games releasing I couldn't justify
pouring hours into the sci-fi shooter
every day or even every week yes the
games mechanics are airtight and as a
fan of shooters I have to tip my hat to
Bungie and I don't judge anyone who has
stuck with destiny - since its release
but within this sci-fi universe
I never really felt in control of the
outcome and barring any major overhauls
- the way destiny to inherently
functions I decided to avoid this type
of game and buy this type of game I'm
talking about lifestyle games
the YouTube channel extra credits
defines these as titles you play more
than any other games you make friends
through games you play on a regular
basis over long periods of time they
often have daily chores to accomplish
they can come from any number of genres
from MMORPGs to MOBAs sports titles to
shooters
these are games you keep returning to
time and time again sometimes out of
habit in recent years we've often seen
games less as discrete experiences and
more as services to me destiny is the
prime example ubisoft's the division
also aimed to scratch that itch and
based on everything we've heard so far
it seems like Bioware xantham will
follow in the same vein but before all
of these games existed there was monster
hunter if you've been playing since the
series beginning in 2004 then you know
how much of a lifestyle game each
Monster Hunter entry can be but as
someone who only just stoven to the
franchise with monster hunter world I
was astounded to find many of the same
characteristics as the aforementioned
games chief among them being destiny and
what's more I was taken off-guard by
just how many things Monster Hunter does
better
I know I just said I was swearing off
this type of game but hear me out
although Monster Hunter is designed to
be a time sink and many of its quests
and events will likely become repetitive
over hundreds of hours it actually gives
you control over much of the outcome yes
there is RNG involved with certain item
drops and limited time events but
throughout my time with Monster Hunter
World I never feel as if I'm wasting it
that's because the game embraces an idea
that destiny and the division rarely do
agency for instance I want to craft the
irathient armor set so I set out to hunt
a Ratheon to complete the set I need a
Ratheon spike an item that sometimes
won't drop and in this case it didn't
this was bad luck
what sets monster hunter apart is the
fact that I can greatly increase my
chances of getting that spike next time
by severing the creatures tail it gives
me more control than I might otherwise
have in destiny I would have repeated
the same strike or raid boss shooting at
it ad nauseam until it died hoping it
would drop the armor piece I need it yes
you can pop a three of coins in the hope
of buffing your chances at better loot
but you never really know if your
efforts will come to fruition in Monster
Hunter your intentions mean much more
the same rings true with armor and
weapon crafting unlike in destiny you're
not waiting for the weapon you want to
drop with the exact modifiers you need
in monster hunter you set your goals you
hunt the intended monsters gather the
necessary parts and you control the
weapon modifiers you work for
furthermore our monster hunters focus on
agency results in more chances to
prepare for upcoming assignments I can
eat specific meals for certain stat
boosts I can outfit my palico cat
companion with stronger gear I can equip
myself with the armor most resistant to
the next monster is bleeding attacks I
can also accept the most useful bounties
for the hunting grounds I'm heading into
ensuring I'll have upgrade points to
spend on existing armor or to reinforce
new ones this brings me to my next point
in Monster Hunter very few rewards feel
useless while destiny supplies a
constant slew of boots
robes weapons gauntlets and class items
most of it will be cast aside or
converted into some sort of currency in
the late-game stages in monster hunter
world however that Rado bond armor can
remain useful in the later hours
especially when you upgrade it to its
alpha or beta forms allowing for gems
that increase certain resistances aiding
you in your fight against the high-level
opponent this all results in as my
coworker John Lucas said a much blurrier
line between the early game and
late-game
in destiny and the division the first
half felt like a completely separate
experience from the latter in monster
hunter world it all feels cohesive once
again conveying the feeling that every
hour a spend will contribute to my goals
I'll use numerous load outs after dozens
of hours I'll swap between weapon types
as I hunt new monsters I'll gather herbs
for potions and bugs to make traps it
all feels worthwhile because it all
encourages self-improvement I'm not just
grinding to reach the endgame but
enjoying the journey there in the first
place the control freak and me
appreciates monster hunters habit of
respecting my time
it makes destiny and the division feel
almost obsolete in their current forms
if I'm going to pour days or weeks into
a single game I want to know what values
my effort I may have sworn off these so
called life style games for a while but
Monster Hunter world has me hooked and
it's nice to not feel exploited
[Music]